this is a case with many questions left
an answer answered and there's been
widespread speculation ever since
claudia lawrence's disappearance as you
mentioned there over the years the
police have always said that they
believed that she was murdered but
nobody has been found and despite two
investigations no charges have been
brought but now north yorkshire police
have confirmed that they are searching
gravel pits to the east of york eight
miles from where claudia lawrence used
to live
we have heard from the superintendent
wayne fox from north yorkshire police he
has uploaded a statement to their
website which we can listen to now
the searches which you've commenced here
today at sandhunk and gravel pits
are in relation to the disappearance and
suspected murder of claudia lawrence
more than 12 years ago
i cannot say at this stage how long the
search will take to complete
however i anticipate that specialist
officers staff including underwater
search teams
and forensic experts are likely to be
here for a number of days
while someone able to disclose what has
led us to this location i wish to stress
that the search activity that you'll see
in the coming days
is just one of several active line of
inquiry
north yorkshire police have also said
that this new information that they've
been given appears extremely interesting
and sparks a whole new line of
investigation they've also urged anyone
who's providing this information to get
back in touch to provide as much detail
as possible they've also said that
claudia lawrence's family are aware of
the update sadly her father peter who
campaigned tirelessly over the years to
find information about her disappearance
he died earlier this year not knowing
what had happened to claudia